last time we were on the show we
discussed a little bit that you know
part of your job
is uh occasional occasionally doing a
nude scene
uh on the show and i was curious i'm
always wondering in that situation
what's it like do you warn your mom if
your mom is going to be watching
is your mom cool with that you have to
call your parents how does it work my
mom's cool with whatever i do on the
show because she she's an artist she's a
photographer and she knows that it's
part of the job um
so she understands that it's artistic
and that you know it's written in the
script and that it's not
me doing it um but she's
my mom's 64. um she had me when she was
40.
um and so she's pretty conservative in a
lot of ways
i mean she's actually staying with me
for um she was staying with me for the
christmas new year's break and
so when i was leaving my house in this
dress um and every time i wear a dress
or a skirt she will always say to me
are you wearing panties my mom's from
new york are you wearing panties and
i'll say
yes mom and she'll say big ones and i'll
say
yes mom big ones and she's like you know
you can wear two pair
because she's so concerned she's like
you know the paparazzi they love those
up the skirt shots they're gonna they're
gonna get you in a picture in your
gatkas
so you're what you're gatkas that's like
your little
your she calls it a tongue your thong oh
okay i was just
once again you've wiped my mind clean
yeah i'm gonna eat my mom loves
invisible panty line just so
the first solution is two pairs of
panties because
that would really get you talked about
in the if the paparazzi photo emerged if
you're wearing multiple pairs of
underwear
that would get more granny pants
big polka dots on them so just in case
there is a shot they can't mistake it
for flesh it's definitely
just polka dots right or just uh
people's faces on them you know
like obama
that was the first face that came to my
mind
not the face i was thinking of uh
i own underwear that has my face on it
you go visit your old haunts because i
know that you were
you did the theater there for a long
time do you walk around and visit the
old sites when you were in new york did
i i went back to the opera i sang in the
children's chorus i went back to my old
school and
um when i was training at the opera when
i was i started when i was seven and
eight for the children's chorus and they
used to teach us all these new arias and
i also went to a school and so my
my route when i would walk home from
from opera practice was actually
past this butcher this like big fancy
madison avenue butcher i
i love to eat um and so i would stop in
at the butchers and if i could sing them
in aria
they would give me a hot dog really yes
so that was my after school snack
this just seems somehow cruel like
you're a child you're hungry you're
coming home from school they're like hey
we'll give you a little food if you sing
for us
yes and in fact they they didn't like
any encore presentations it always had
to be new material so you're out there
i'm just picturing you
singing uh just singing like crazy to
get a hot dog
what an interesting scene it became a
thing that i did like they were like oh
that cute girl girls
i don't know why i did that voice but
yeah the cute the girl who wants you to
have a pizza pie
oh god the dog yes so i went back in
there and i thought about doing it but
they didn't recognize me and then i was
i was sad because you know i'm not seven
anymore right when you walk
in now and say hey i'll sing for that
hot dog it just
you know it's down right no it doesn't
the uh i have to buy the hot dogs now i
heard about this and i thought i just
want to hear i just thought maybe this
would inspire you i heard about this so
uh
i had a hot dog prepared maybe you would
if i hold it out here maybe you would
maybe you would just candy come on guys
i have been behind you on so much but
this i just
i am appalled
if you'd come to rehearsal you'd know
what's going on
[Laughter]
usually usually singers are allowed to
vocalize before
they they sing okay do what you got to
do
okay i'm good i'm nervous now i'm the
guy from the old butcher shop
you're one of the hot dogs
foreign
[Applause]
it's a good hot dog that was beautiful
thank you
that clip will be my legacy when i'm
long gone